大家分享一个我个人或去拆复的方法,特别简单
就像一场时一通逐迫
但是特别奇怪
百分之九之一的人
却觉得你同迫的样子
那怕没有任何风险
给大家分享三个特别的简单,但是违反人们认知的常识
然后想哪儿说哪儿,我不准备解释
因为
真正有想法的人他一定会自去做么这个事
首先第一,我这个人是特别喜欢困难的
烦猫的
我
我把它当作是一个
竞渡条
大家把我游戏吗
你打个报索竞渡条,他都要打多少,过了个机关,对我特别喜欢
我不但喜欢自己遇到的困难和麻烦
我还喜欢收集别人的困难和麻烦,说过经常问你为什么困难你为什么困难你为什么困难
然后遇到一个
特别棒的困难的时候,我就输货之宝
我有空的时候就会去想
这个困难我可以怎么解决呀
对吧
一旦解决他我就认为我拥有的一项制裁,什么制裁问题解决发言
我相信这个世界上
只要有的问题
不是我一个人遇到,一定会有很多人遇到
一旦我遇到解决发言的话,我就会获取的财富
所以我不逃避困难
甚至上我会逃,我会特别喜欢困难,这是第一个
然后第二个人是,我不害怕失败
而且我很喜欢失败
我家两天分享了一个
我认为非常帮的一个
创意的方法,叫经验创意法,结果好准都噴我
上他嘴巴,这个人不是啥就是坏
就是他们不愿意了解,我后面说了什么
一个钱条件
只要这个事情
没有成本
或者成本非常低的情况下
我个人就会尝试,是败了有所谓
失败了再来,是否在下来
给大家分享一个我在投资的时候,获得的一个礼物,这个礼物度的帮助特别大
就是如果我投资
失败了九次
但是只要这九次没有什么
太大的损失,我拿怕成功一次
那么我的收益就会非常非常的大
所以我只要面对击乎没什么成本
然后或者成本非常低的情况下,我就愿意尝试,失败了无所谓
但是一个特别奇怪的现象是
生活中
越是没面子的人
他又越特别再越自己的面子
生活中
越是时间越是不值钱的人
他在看一些有用的支持的时候
他越在自己的时间成本,这个才怪呢
这是我讲的第二个人是
一会儿把他联系来啊
然后第三个人是
我
喜欢分享过知道的一切
是一切
包括赚钱的方法
就好多人说
赚钱的方法为什么分享给别人,你是啥吗
各位,如果就在一个现成里
只有我知道这个技术
而且这是我唯一赖以生存的
技能
我是不会分享给你的,因为你学会了我就没法生存
可是在
广闊的互联网下
这个又不是我唯一生存的技能
我分享给你
对我对这个社会都是有好处的
好多不理解
不要紧
这三条你认真处理解,每一项都可以帮你获取财富,但是如果你能把他联在一起的话
就不一样了,比如说你发现了一个问题,不管是你的还是别认的
然后你认为这个问题
对大多数人来很重要,你找到一个几个分案
然后你去嘗试他
对吧
怎么嘗试呢,如果没有什么成本的话,你就去嘗试找到一个几个分案
然后让所有的人可见,分享你是到一切,你是不是有这个问题,你是不是不会拍点视频
你是不是不会学习,你是不是不会创业,你是不是不会做BBT,你是不是不会什么
我分享跟你,但是我没有什么成本
分享给你
然后看看有问题,觉得你是不是需要这个,你是不是需要这个,你不需要
不要紧,我还有一个问题
还有一个问题,还有一个结婚
你是不是需要这个,不会不需要,不要紧
还有一个问题一个结婚,注意
我每作一次,我认为就是我的一次嘗试,你可以认为他是失败
这个失败对我来说,没有任何成本,你看问题是百问题是百问题是百
问题
有人关心了,哦,我需要这个,哦,那么你以为我这个
问题,认为,你细节上还有什么问题,我可以帮你,我都是免非都
然后我帮你,不干的改革,不干的改革,不干的问题,不干的改革
我终于找到一条
这个问题,很多人都感兴趣,可以帮助很多人的结婚
不断地去改革他,不断地
分享,不断地改革他,不断地分享,当这个结婚
可以帮助越来越多的人的时候
他就是我采负的来源
所以各位,好好替问曾经话,第一
我从来
我特别喜欢
遇到困难和麻烦
我认为那是获取成功的进度条
我不害怕失败
只要这个事没有什么成本,或者什么很低
那就失败,好了,如果不行再来一次,不行再来一次
然后第三步,就是
在
没有的你跑到一个
向人民分享,你做知道的
一切
慢慢提挥